It seem like
I can't remember nothing no more.
I try to say what day it is.
I ain't got a clue.
I wrote The Last Days of Ptolemy Grey
as a celebration of my parents' lives.
My father had a kind of cancer
that caused dementia,
and my mother
had another kind of dementia.
And so, the reason I'm so happy
to make the 6 episode miniseries
is because there's a depth to the series
that's very powerful.
And I feel that seeing this
is gonna have a big effect
on how you'll see people,
you know, going through dementia.
What if it's you who can't remember
from one word to the next?
When you have a loved one
that doesn't know who you are anymore,
it's like the most heartbreaking thing
in the world.
I come from a family
where there are a lot of people
who have dementia or Alzheimer's.
So I'm kind of surrounded by it.
So, I've been trying
to do this project for like ten years.
I have been told
that you have been forgetting things.
I remember what's important.
Walter and I got a call from Sam one day.
He read the book, and he asked us
what we were doing with it.
And that, honestly, is how it started.
Just his love and passion for this story.
I told Walter, "I just need you
to change it into cinematic form
so we can get it told
in the way it feels from the book."
Because I've always loved
the integrity of the story.
I'm really grateful for Sam
for really wanting to do it.
Sam has really reached out
for the humanity of this character.
You don't know whether
to hate your condition
or to hate yourself.
You can't translate one art into another
and have it stay the same.
But what I tried to do in the book,
and I think I might be a little bit
even more successful in the series,
is to humanize people, you know,
going through dementia.
Old folks ain't scared of life.
They already got one foot in the grave.
On the set, people have
really taken the story to heart
and wanted to figure out
how they could make this feeling,
that I had originally but we all have now,
how to make that the best it can be.
I'm just trying
to make things better for you.
Better don't sound so bad, do it?
If we want to be better people,
then it's important for us
to acknowledge that,
at the end of the day,
we all just need each other.
I want people to be able to
look at this story
and know that
there is a way to care for people
and be gentle with them
in their time of need.
Wouldn't be no me sitting here
if you wasn't sitting next to me.
When you're having people put that kind
of energy into making the series,
that's really edifying.